We have a voicemail number.
That number is two.
One nine two, David P, uh, yesterday I talked
about the cult like nature of Trumpists, both
a cult of personality around Trump, but also
the very cult like behavior of many of Trump's
followers, which includes, um, uh, always
finding reasons why the bad things that Trump
does aren't really bad.
Ignoring information about bad things that
Donald Trump does.
We talked about it all before.
I got a voicemail yesterday from a Trumpist
who says he is not pleased with me making
the cultist analogy.
Take a listen to this.
Yeah.
Just watch your show.
Will you, um, lambasted, uh, Tucker Carlson
and I'm a Trump supporter and there are 62
million of us, or 60 million of us, and you're
really condescending and insulting to us that
we're not smart enough to think on her own
or how we're gonna pay for something.
I'm, I mean, it's ridiculous the way you talk
about us, that we're a cult.
Are you kidding me?
No one's going to put me in a Colt.
No politician is going to brainwash me into
voting for them.
Yeah.
I mean, you know, one of the things that's
important to understand about cults is nobody
who's in a cult thinks they're in a cult until
sometimes after they've left the cult.
No one who is brainwashed believes that they
have been brainwashed.
Because knowing you've been brainwashed would
be an antidote to the brainwashing.
And the reality is a lot of people who voted
for Trump are ignorant people.
I, I've said before, there's ignorant people
on all sides of the political spectrum.
If someone in an uninformed way votes for
a Democrat or a progressive or whatever, it's
not any less informed than an ignorant Republican
voter.
I would be glad if they end up making the
right decision.
But there's uninformed and ignorant voters
on both sides.
But as I said before, there are basically
three categories of people who voted for Donald
Trump.
And I know this pisses a lot of people off
there.
Ignorant people, right?
People who just didn't know what they were
voting for, they didn't understand they were,
they either fell for things Trump said that
were impossible and said, this is why I'm
gonna vote for the guy without realizing that
the, the, the, the, the, they were impossible
promises or they just don't pay attention
to the politics.
Ignorance to some degree.
There are people who are cognitively limited
and that, again, I'm not insulting anybody,
it's just there's a lot of people in, in the
electorate who vote, but they don't really
have the cognitive capacity to understand
what is going on.
It's not ignorance, but it's a limitation.
And then you have just what I would call bad
people and I know that good, bad is, it's
a very rudimentary and unsophisticated way
to categorize.
But what I mean by bad people is it's not
people who are cognitively limited.
It's not people who are ignorant to the facts.
It's people who understand exactly what it
is that Donald Trump is promising and they
like it, right?
They like it because it's good for them personally
because of taxes, for example, or whatever.
Those are the three categories.
I've still not met anyone to this day who
voted for Trump, who doesn't fall into one
of those three categories and I will completely
concede to you that there are people on the
left, at least with two of those three categories
that we could identify as well.
Prove me wrong.
I'm open to having my mind changed.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about the repositioning of a
coalition forces thanks to Donald Trump's
Iran belligerence.
We will talk about CNBC using the wrong pictures
on screen for presidential candidates, Andrew
Yang and tool C Gabbert and we will also talk
about kids who have been shot after throwing
snowballs at passing cars.
This reminds me of something former producers
[inaudible]
Louis and I used to do all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show.
Get instant access by signing up@joinedpacman.com
[inaudible]
the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].